with the president of the European
Council Char Michelle and followed by
the president of the European commission
also have on line
[Music]
president
for
con
en
a third priority for all of us is the
foreign policy and and security uh we
want to work with those uh leaders to
make sure that we have more alignment we
Face extraordinary difficult challenges
with the war launched by Russia against
Ukraine and that's why is so important
to speak with one voice to act in the
same uh Direction and to do everything
to protect our common values to protect
our interest is another field where we
want to strengthen our cooperation we
also want to cooperate more in the field
of the fight against disinformation
about cyber and hybrid attacks and we
also want to uh cooperate more and
better in the field of migration we give
this example the Visa policy is an
important tool and wein it more
cooperation more in this field is also
important finally one one last word the
European Union's project is based on
reconciliation uh is based on uh a
common will for the future to build more
Prosperity uh more security more more
peace more stability and that's why
resolving uh the disputes resolving the
conflicts is so important and that's why
we have also encouraged all the leaders
present to
to weable the efforts to resolve the
disputes and to resolve the the
conflicts
thank you very much president Vine yeah
thank you so much indeed we had a very
good discussion at this Summit um The
Summit takes place around a month after
the commission's report on
enlargement and um we um also discussed
uh the state of play with the backdrop
of this enlargement report to recall we
want to open accession negotiations on
the first so-called fundamentals cluster
as soon as possible with Albania and
North
Macedonia we consider that we can open
uh accession negotiation with with
Bosnia heroa one once the necessary
degree of compliance with the membership
criteria is achieved when it comes to
Montenegro um there is a new momentum in
the country with the new government to
get back on track on its accession path
and finally for both Kosovo and Serbia
the way ahead lies in living up to their
commitments under the EU dialogue they
have taken important steps forward this
year with the Orit agreement which must
now be implemented and um I very much
welcome the decrease of tensions in the
north of Kosovo in particular on the
license plates on electricity and on
preparing for early Municipal
elections this is the backdrop against
which we have discussed of course
accession negotiations are one part of
our effort to bring the Western Balkans
closer but the other part is to look at
the econ economy if you look at the
Western balcan economies they stand
today at around 35% of the EU average in
other words there's a lot of untapped
potential and this is what the new
growth plan is looking at there was a
lot of praise for the new growth plan
the new growth plan has basically four
principles or four pillars the first one
is to say we the European Union we open
our Market in seven important sectors to
the Western
Balkans for example coroporation on
Customs cashless payment seamless
transport roaming like at home and other
sectors that are
important secondly we ask the uh Western
Balan to open their markets respectively
to their neighbors so to really complete
the common regional market if the common
regional market would be completed I'm
not speaking of the single Market but
the Western Balkan common regional
market this could increase the GDP of
the western Balkans by 10% so there's a
lot of music in
it um the third element is to have the
Western Balkans um accessing the single
Market we need a Level Playing Field
therefore reforms have to be done in the
western Balkans and the fourth element
is then investment that is the growth
plan that says you do reforms here is
the investment that accompanies those
reforms investment and reform is a
principle that you are familiar with
from Next Generation EU um we mirror
that here in the new growth Plan and the
New Growth plan has the potential to
double the size of the Region's economy
within a
decade of course this is the big picture
but there are also lots of good steps
smaller steps forward take roaming since
the 1 of October roaming charges have
been cut by 90% thanks to the operators
working together now we're working on a
full roam like at home framework to make
it permanent or if you take transport we
now have a road map for the
modernization of border crossings agreed
by the partners today this is seamless
Customs procedures between us these are
good for the easier integration in the
EU single Market that means more
business more trade more Investments
speaking of Investments we also looked
at the already working economic and
investment plan you are familiar with it
30 billion for the Western balcans it
has already delivered 17 billion and
today a fresh batch of five more
projects worth nearly 700 million EUR
was adopted be it a solar photovoltaic
power plant in Albania for example or a
railway in
Montenegro um these are the projects
that we are pushing forward with the
economic and investment plan on digital
there were good news because we now want
to extend the Wii 4 EU program to the
Western Balkans that means bringing 15
million EUR of Grants to make it
possible for 400 municipalities to have
WiFi for Western Balkan in their
area and finally young
people the most precious part um of our
lives in October we were happy and
honored to open the local office of the
College of Europe in tyana I can report
that by now 500 students have already
applied to come and to study their next
years near the European Union will
finance 15 scholarship and today we had
a pledging moment uh 21 member states
promis to pledge for scholarship so this
is big news and good news for the region
I think this is it for the moment and
I'm happy to answer question thank you
president we'll start with
questions
Ara
[Music]
conf
VI
for
op
we have the commission report and indeed
this uh shows that there are lots of
good arguments uh for the move forward
on the accession process of the
different uh countries the process is
Merit based and I think this is on one
hand and encouragement to uh the
candidate countries uh to earn these
merits so to do the reforms that are
necessary but I think merits based also
means for us in the European Union that
we have to acknowledge if Merit is there
and has been gained by um the candidate
countries this will be the discussion
tomorrow and it will certainly be a
broad
discussion thank you very much we
continue with questions if there are
more question if not then we wrap up
here theid press conference and thank
you for
coming
a third priority for all of us is the
more more peace more stability and
that's why resolving uh the state of
play with the backdrop of this
enlargement report to recall the first
one is to say we the European Union we
open our Market speaking of the single
Market but the Western Balkan common
regional market this could increase
their markets respectively to their
neighbors so to really complete here in
the new growth Plan and the New Growth
plan has the
potential we also looked at the already
working economic and investment and
investment plan on digital there were
good news because
we